taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
buddies hey hi guys we got another one
coming at you time for another hot
debate
taste buds taste buds i am savicano i'm
joe derosa
i'll still get hung up to bring it into
food terms on the chicken or the egg
thing
still what came first i still get hung
up on it
yeah which it's impossible
yeah well what do we do we come from
fish
i don't know i get we're
related to like like the chart of
evolution but where did the first
monkey come from all life comes from
bacteria from the
water i believe right right i think so
right
did they ever prove where chickens
chicken or the egg i mean it must have
been something laid the egg first right
it had to be it had to be right
basically many many moons ago there was
a chicken-like bird
so in a nutshell or an eggshell
two birds that weren't really chickens
created a chicken egg and hence we
haven't answered the egg okay who
created that bird
hello it was a it was a it was a more of
a mammalian i guess
kind of thing that just gave birth
without eggs
what what what i said it was more of a
mammalian kind of a thing
that gave birth without eggs is it a
million something that gives birth
without eggs
mammal oh okay
look it is like 10 o'clock at night i've
been
i've been podcasting since noon or one i
don't know it's insane
uh i'm a million oh i'm a million oh but
i never heard someone call him a million
yeah i've never heard that yeah yeah
i almost thought you were naming it now
that you say it i it becomes obvious i'm
a little bit punch drunk myself but
mamillion i've never heard someone use
that yeah mammalian or mammalian
mammalian i probably said it wrong
mammalian is different mammalian mammal
oh if you said mammalian i might have
maybe
connected the dots i think you i don't
think you would mammalian is
not right i don't think you i don't
think you would harm
a mammal but but okay well then so yeah
right so
so but wait what
how did the first mammal where's go back
everything's just from back but
we don't have time these are half hour
eps you're trying to trace the beginning
of life right now
we got a debate to do
[Laughter]
man we are going from the the existence
and question of eternal being
to what's what juice is better it's just
yeah let's
where we at time was mike
all right he's homeless let's launch the
let's launch the debate and then we'll
we'll maybe during the debate we can
come back to how
life began okay yeah yeah uh which is
you know an argument that uh when the
which which juice came scientists are
still having what's that i wonder which
juice came first why do you lead it let
it lead us into this joey
lead us in yeah lead us in introduce the
uh
this is an interesting one now this this
this one came up on one of the
first group of episodes we recorded
um some i don't remember what we were
discussing but somehow we got into
orange briefly orange juice versus apple
juice
and sal said that he thought
orange juice was the superior juice best
drink of all time blah blah blah
i said apple juice beats orange juice he
strongly disagreed
which was confusing to me because we
once had a conversation
uh the two of us uh and we were
quite a few drinks in where we named our
favorite drinks of all time our top
five yeah and i remember martinelli's
apple juice was on the list
for both of us we we we bonded on
martinelli's being shout out
martinelli's
so good uh so i'm surprised that you
took such a hard stance about
orange juice it doesn't indicate how i
feel about martinelli some of these
episodes i won't
disagree that i like the thing you're
arguing for but head to head
orange juice is the king of all juice i
mean
in my opinion apple juice is the best
juice and i have more to say but let's
launch the twitter pullback
okay here we go better juice apple
orange that tweet is out
okay uh look here's the thing
there was a time where i loved orange
juice
as a young boy uh the older i get
uh if orange juice doesn't have vodka in
it i can't be bothered
i'm gonna be honest with you i love a
screwdriver
uh can i bat this around back and forth
or do you cause i have something to say
on the heels of that
go ahead something i never thought of
until you just mentioned that not that
this makes it a better juice because i
want to stop having arguments
where we attach the product to other
things when it suits us
but okay apple juice is really
fairly not used
as a mixer or with any kind of tail
spirit whatsoever
never except hard cider i stand
completely corrected
there is an entire industry based around
it yeah
i didn't really apple juice i didn't
include but i guess apple cider
i actually strike that from the record
it's it's there's there's yeah there's a
there's a uh christmas punch you can
make which i have made on christmas day
for my family
uh oh god spike
hot cider so waffle is whiskey what am i
talking about yeah whiskey is
russell excuse me is whiskey with apple
cider vinegar cinnamon sticks it's
delicious it's just not a bar drink
a traditional bar drink now now also
cider is not
apple juice but i do think that it
counts in support of the
the strengthening the argument of the
the worth of apple juice it's a
variation of apple juice
um we didn't say cider okay but i mean
it's it's
it's it's pretty much apple juice you
know
yeah i guess it's once this is a thicker
more like
hearty maybe it's possibly processed
differently
yeah yeah sure it's got more of the
maybe is is it better for you or it's
just sweeter
i can't imagine a world apple juice
official description from massachusetts
department of agriculture says cider is
raw apple juice oh okay it is better for
you
that has not undergone a filtration
process to remove coarse particles of
pulp or sediment
basically like like uh apple juice with
pulp
maybe yeah but i also think they
probably aren't adding a lot of sugar to
cider
uh whereas apple juice and cider is much
more like it doesn't yes see
they add they pasteurize it and add
preservatives uh to extend the shelf
life
because i don't think you get cider like
like it's not good for as good as long
as like a an apple juice is like you
can't put it in your fridge for like a
year i don't think or whatever
so here's my thing here's my thing the
apple as a fruit
let's start at the base the apple is a
fruit just
a far superior fruit i know you're the
orange you won you want you slaughtered
me
as a nucleus of your argument and you
can extend into the juice i didn't say
that just yet
okay i didn't say that just yet but the
apple is a far superior
fruit than the orange i don't agree with
you whatsoever far superior i don't
agree with you
there's versatility either the orange is
better than the apple
that's even as a fruit the orange is the
orange that's all it ever is
i i have to be like i guess i'll eat an
apple
i mean you put an orange in front of me
i'm like do you have a second orange you
got a ruby red apple
you got a uh a granny smith you got a
green apple
you could name apples you got it
delicious yeah they're
wonderful the flavors every time i bite
into an apple i'm like all right it's a
waxy
um so it's a waxy skin that gets caught
in the middle of my teeth
and then you start chopping on the apple
and it gets like foamy and sudsy a
little bit
and it's always a little tart or bitter
and then you swallow it and like every
time you bite into it too it's like i
feel like it's ripping into my gums
and ultimately it's okay
but like you slice up a nice orange
you quarter it you put it into segments
and like you just rip it and you rip the
skin off and you bite it and the juice
is bursting and it's just
alive in your mouth it's it's it's it's
it's just vibrant
it's it's it's it's refreshing it's like
it pops orange juice you know what i
mean
it really it it the sugar in
natural sugar and orange is so much more
i think
palatable than than when i bite into an
apple and apple's like
kind of like weirdly sticky and
i don't know i don't love the texture i
find the orange to be
one of the most boring fruits i never
buy oranges ever
i buy cherries i buy peaches i buy
strawberries i buy blueberries i buy
apples i buy bananas
i buy uh uh uh uh
uh what are they called uh
they put it in sushi you know you buy
pears pears
they put it at mango i love a mango okay
never ever do i buy orange it's funny
because i what you just said is how i
feel about apples
i think it's the most boring fruit ever
i think it's like i told you what they
do with apples when i argue the apple
pie
like please come bring your friends and
family for five dollars
take as many goddamn apples as you can
put in your arms all right
just fill your sweatshirts up fill your
pockets take baskets
we don't need to weigh it right right
five dollars come in here just take
the goddamn apples there's so many
apples
just take them you see an orange tree
yeah i had one in my yard in l.a i mean
it's good
never picked an orange off at once what
does it matter with you something's
wrong with you i had lemon trees why did
you have an
orange tree it was there when i moved in
and i said you can stay there for a like
you still didn't you didn't pick a fresh
homemade orange not once did i pick a
lemon or an orange off my own orange and
lemon tree
didn't give a rat's ass not even a lemon
make yourself some homemade lemonade
put a lemon in a you know just for a
shrimp cocktail
put it over a piece of what have you
talking lemons we're talking oranges
we're talking apples at oranges you
don't like the taste of an orange
i like it fine but i couldn't give a
[ __ ]
i don't care listen we're getting
sidetracked i even like the texture
of an orange yeah okay fine let me tell
you why the orange juice is bad
it's not bad i like orange juice i like
it all right but let me tell you what's
the inferior
all right it's too acidic all right a
lot of the time
bad orange juice is real bad
you got to really find good orange juice
and you got a lot of
bad brands of orange shoes now this
isn't what i criticize you for where i
go sal of course there's a bad version
of everything
that's not what i'm saying what i'm
saying is
most orange juices you would pluck off
your supermarket shelf
i agree with are bad i agree with you
but i'm not talking about a brand of bad
orange juice
i'm talking about give me your best
glass of orange juice versus your best
glass of apple juice and i will tell you
this
martinelli's knows what they're doing
but apple juice for me
is pretty redundant i don't a lot of
times i don't taste the difference
if i have a cup of apple juice from
somewhere and a couple apple juices your
house or a cup of aperture somewhere
else
it tastes the same to me the same apple
juice because it's the nectar of the
gods
it's being i don't know they don't have
to do anything but
where is it we're taking a superior
fruit and creating juice out of it and
it always tastes good you ever have a
beautiful fresh squeezed
glass of orange juice what are we
talking here i mean if you if you
juice an apple and drink it it's not
good it's apple cider it's delicious
it's not that i drink it every
thanksgiving halloween through
thanksgiving i drink that's cool because
everyone else drinks orange juice every
morning for breakfast
oh so you can dip into the apple juice
do you think you could wake up every day
and have a glass of apple juice
every single day i think it would get a
little old i mean don't get me wrong i
have
apple juice infrequently enough to
always enjoy the glass of it
but i don't know if i could drink apple
juice
as frequently as i drink orange juice
and i'll show you another thing
honestly i could have orange juice any
time and i dunk
i even that this is another story for
another day but like
it's almost like embedded itself
indelibly into breakfast
even though you could have it anytime
and socially in drinks and cocktails but
like
sometimes i don't even feel like i'll
have a water or a coffee or a tea with
breakfast
but sometimes when i'm having toast eggs
or bacon you
there's something that is has evolved in
our dna where i feel like you need to
taste orange juice
during a hearty breakfast meal like that
to complete a breakfast experience
when when a drink when a beverage can
accomplish
that much i think it is a heavy hitter
beverage
that needs to be respected and i cannot
say the same
for apple juice i cannot apply it
absolutely to basically
this is ingrained in in society and it
has its place in
it is the king breakfast beverage you
love far none you love going to this
argument of
what society does and it's never polling
i know but i'm saying like it's not the
strongest it's not the strongest uh
thing to support your argument is my
point doesn't speak to quality
necessarily is my point now here's the
thing
when i eat pancakes i always get a black
coffee and an orange juice with it
pancakes or waffles
pancakes waffles mark it down
write it down write it down right now uh
i love waffles i love pancakes but but
i mean unless it's an eggo you can get
it out of my face
and eggo yeah i'm not talking frozen
food babe
i'm talking poor but pour some batter
pull pull throw a belgium on my plate
what are you bonkers won't even look at
it at the breakfast buffet
i won't even listen let's save it let's
save it
let's save it okay now i'm talking
standard waffle
hold on for standard pancakes we gotta
show you throw a blueberry burn it out
don't burn it out yeah standard waffle
versus standard pancake yeah i don't put
anything in my pancakes
buttermilk that's it i i love pancakes
hold on
i need to be in the mood but if i if i'm
if i'm really questioning pancake for
swapping i'm gonna ruin an episode okay
okay you gotta stop
[Laughter]
okay listen here's my point when i ate
pancakes
i drink orange juice with it i love it
it's a beautiful combo i like it quite a
bit
but i am telling this if i slept on this
very couch
today that you have okay right yeah yes
and then i woke up tomorrow morning and
you were standing over me
as you often are then i wake up
and you said to me you want some juice
my first pick would be apple why because
you don't have it as much it's a treat
it's not it's not that it's because i
know
i can trust it to be delicious orange
juice when it's bad
look there's no worse juice on planet
earth
than the [ __ ] plastic tropicana
orange juice bottles
the singles that you get into the jelly
but maybe they're from
concentrate they're they are terrible
anything from concentrate is and
look don't don't get me wrong that one
right there not no not that don't get me
wrong
no that's
but that's from concentrate that's
literally nonsense you
cannot that cannot even be in this
conversation you want to talk a simply
orange i'll drink it
i love it simply orange you know but let
me even tell you this tropicana when i
was younger
every single and this is nothing against
anyone but like i don't want to hear
but like i feel like everything when i
was younger was different
than now and it was just of a higher
taste in quality
over the course of years and market like
the way the market trends and everything
you know corners are cut ingredients are
are less quality less fresh portions are
cut down
when they're marketed and and and that's
the way of the world
so i feel like if i had a glass of
tropicana for when i was 10
and a glass of tropicana from today that
tropicana at least in my head
tasted better now nothing against
tropicana now it's still my number one
go-to
juice off the shelf over simply orange
i'll take a simple orange no problem
i'll take a simply i like simply
simply orange is the king of orange
juice nobody tops simply orange
nobody i mean it's it's okay i mean no
no no it's simply
get yourself a trader joe's fresh
squeezed
simply orange is it it's the it's it's
the closest to fresh squeeze you can get
in the supermarket the orange is very
delicious
but you're putting tropicana above
simply or not necessarily
okay fine trader joe's fresh squeezed
is what you're saying actually there's
another there's another brand in that
i wish i could recall it uh it's but
it's the same vein it's it's a small
company like a mom and pop company it's
a
fresh squeezed orange juice company and
it it literally blew me away
when i had it and i would put that juice
up against anybody
orange juice nine times out of ten and
you're not going to believe this because
i
because i drink grapefruit juice
sometimes orange juice nine times out of
ten gives me a stomach ache
nine times out of ten then how do you
drink grapefruit juice i don't know i
can't believe we're drinking is like
take all the fun out of the orange juice
and take all the worst parts of a bad
orange juice
and triple it for grapefruit juice
grapefruit juice
we already agree we already found out
and if we didn't then this is a spoiler
let's not talk about it all right let's
not talk about it my point is is nine
times out of ten
orange juice gives me a stomachache also
like i said i enjoy a screwdriver i love
a screwdriver
i can have two screwdrivers they're not
meant to be drank
before i'm like this is get it away from
me i'm going to get sick
apple juice i could drink i'm going to
make an apple juice and vodka and the
same with grape juice
i could drink glass after glass after
glass
grape juice is an unsung hero but it's
just too sweet
i would take it over orange juice in the
morning
i it's something about citrus i need
citrus in my life
i don't like citrus in the morning i'm
not a huge fan of it i can do it
well i've done it i used to do it a lot
more now i can't because i get like i
get like
unless i have like a lot of food or and
i'll have like half a glass but i used
to pound orange juice i can't do it
anymore
it doesn't take away though what i'm
battling here which is the fact that
just there's a reason that orange juice
sits where it does there's a reason that
it's the number one breakfast beverage
and apple
juice is not for sure apple juice has
been around nearly as
long as orange juice why has orange
juice become
king in every category over apple juice
simply because
people are responding to their taste and
over time
it has been proven i don't even have to
have this argument i could just
defer to the fact that orange juice is
the most popular do we define what
happens for a reason what are we
deferring to
what are we deferring to you're telling
me a match apple juice
you think that that's not as good as a
tropicana orange juice
you're nuts no i'm thinking no
orange juice has more applications i
crave it more
it goes with more things it's the more
popular
juice uh it's going to win this poll for
sure
and for a reason you know what i'm
saying it's it's for a reason
i'm going to go back to my argument by
the way
is underrated in a way because i
i like apple juice and most people do i
i hear people say oh i don't like orange
juice i hear that
but i don't normally i don't often hear
people say i don't like apple juice i'll
give you that
but in that respect apple juice really
is
good but like you associate with a
couple things you associate it with
the holidays with like ciders and spices
and then you also associate it with
children
like children drink apple juice with
their sandwich with their lunch when
you're a little
apple juice you give a kid yeah and i
know i know it destroys teeth
but like like you don't give a kid like
orange juice you put in their sippy cup
apple juice so
that's where it carved its niche out now
so ask yourself what you're watching for
why because you clearly orange is juice
is a dangerous juice that you can't give
it to children
and i believe personally the children
are the future so i'm
yeah sure i'll let them lead the way
right i'm glad to not harm a child with
orange juice
wonderful apple juice ask yourself why
in the course of history
apple had every opportunity that orange
did every opportunity didn't
it did and ask yourself why because of a
system why apple didn't because
that's systematic prejudice like what
because of a systematic prejudice
where's the prejudice because apple pie
is americana
or apple picking is american juice
orange juice
has wormed somehow its way into every
continental breakfast and every hotel
across this people think it's
across this country apple juice is not
given the shot
if if if i could have it my way grape
juice would be right there next to it in
the in the breakfast bar
and you never see grape juice because
there is an unfair prejudice against
these other juices
and and apple juice is getting an orange
juice is getting an unfair push
calling all breakfast buffets and
breakfast bars apple
uh grape juice would be a nice touch it
would be
and have you ever had apple juice at a
breakfast buffet in the morning i may
have
wonderful but i will tell you this
though you're saying that it didn't get
a fair shake and there's a prejudice but
you really are saying that
it's baseless and i i personally believe
america has fallen out of love with
orange juice i want to say
almost every year for the last decade
last year orange juice sales hit their
lowest level in at least 15 years
according to nielsen over the same
period per capita
consumption fell roughly 40
percent with that in mind i still
believe
orange juice will beat apple juice and i
and i also believe they've gotten the
exact
same platform i think apple has failed
to do
to capitalize on the opportunities that
orange juice is the other sally babe
talk to me you notice my felt figure i
do actually i have
yeah i've dropped a few pounds you did
yeah you know what that is
thanks in part two what eating better oh
okay you know how i eat better
magic spoon well yeah did i just do the
thing where i just you had a whole big
whole thing i chopped you off at denise
i had a whole thing sorry about that i
had a whole thing i was gonna say
you don't cut out the foods you love you
just eat the food you love in a better
way
okay and magic spoon helps you do that
growing up
cereal best part of being a kid yeah
still the best part best part of being
an adult yeah right
yeah so when you want to cut down on
sugar and you want to cut down on carbs
you want to cut down on healthy foods
you know
cereal is one of those things you just
toss out the window you go i can't have
it but no
you can have it you just have to have it
in the right way
we're all trying to eat better so here's
a cereal it's going to give you zero
grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
per serving
and only four net grams of carbs 13 to
14 grams of
protein serving is a lot of protein it
is especially for a cereal
yeah a lot of people like you can get
you can that's a source of protein
yeah yeah no doubt don't know that 140
calories you said yeah keto friendly
gluten free grain free soy free low carb
and gmo free
and they got exciting news magic spoon
has released a super delicious new
flavor this is new
because the first i'm hearing of this
birthday cake okay
stop the phones and the presses i didn't
know that there was a new flavor until
we were reading this yeah
and birthday cake has become my favorite
flavor of ice cream
uh i love oh birthday cake cereal why
has nobody done that before
it's available in the special five pack
for a limited time only joe you better
get
you better get going babe all right
build your own box you can do a custom
bundle if you want you have to choose
theirs they have cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter cinnamon if you're
listening from canada
you can get it now too go to
magicspoon.com tastebuds to grab the new
limited edition birthday cake
or a custom bundle of cereal to try
today be sure to use our promo code
tastebuds at checkout to save five bucks
off your first order
uh the offer is now good anywhere in the
us or canada but only when you use our
code at checkout that's taste buds
that's the code tastebudsmagicspoon.com
tastebuds use the code tastebuds
get your taste buds going on the magic
spoon
[Laughter]
sally how you feeling over the last 12
months i
feel like it's been 12 years i hear you
yeah
you know what uh let me talk to you
about one of our sponsors
sure please blue chew mm-hmm yeah i know
what blue chew is it's a unique online
service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra
cialis you've heard of these but they
delivered to you in a chewable form and
a fraction of the cost i've tried these
things
yeah they work baby i think i've told
you the story before
of a long weekend i had in vegas oh yeah
and then a lovely lady friend of mine
said why don't you stay an extra day and
spend some time with me
and you attribute a lot of that to the
power of bishop hello blue chew
and boy did we have a time
[Laughter]
uh well here's the thing that people
really respond to it's an
online prescription service so there's
no visits to the doctor's office
no awkward conversations no waiting in
line at the pharmacy
it just trips right to your door and
it's discreet that's the big one if
you're not
aware of what we're talking about yet
this is a product that is going to give
you
better stronger harder erections and
it's a simple process
to sign up just go to bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you're going to get your
prescription within days
and it's all done online it's so easy
licensed medical providers work with you
to find the right ingredient
and strength for your prescription if
you don't like swallowing pills
there's no problem here this is all
chewable it's made in the usa
they prepare it and ship it direct so it
is actually
cheaper than going to a pharmacy there
is really no
reason no not to do it it just
it checks every box it's better in every
way right so
here we go uh special deal for our
listeners try blue
chew free free i mean that's another big
one
when you use promo code tastebuds to
check out just pay the five bucks for
shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo cod promo
code tastebuds
to receive your first month free and uh
thanks
chew for uh sponsoring for messing with
us the podcast
thing i don't like about orange juice it
repeats on me all morning i'm burping it
back up all morning it's just
the acidity now here's why here's the
difference between that and grapefruit
juice
and this is what i don't like about app
are orange juice orange juice is a sneak
okay with grape juice i know grapefruit
juice i know what i'm getting okay
it's bitter i know what i'm getting i
drink it i enjoy it it's like devil's
best and i'm done
okay orange juice it goes
drink me down i'm so refreshing i taste
so good i'm quenching your thirst
it's not quenching my thirst it's
loading my mouth up with sugar that's
not quenching my thirst
and then it's hiding it's hiding its
acidic acidity
and then that acidity is coming back up
and repeating on me i mean
yes maybe you now me now us
now but like in life that didn't happen
to me early on
i drank orange juice like i was like it
was you know i was the last boy on earth
and there was unlimited oranges
and by the way for a guy for a guy
that loves a versatility in in
loves versatility in a product he ain't
getting [ __ ] out of orange juice dude
there ain't no other orange juice
whatever
juice blends okay but you got cran apple
you got grape apple i don't care about
that which i'm just
i'm just apples i'm just using also what
about vitamins
bro what about vitamins bro i said it
100 of your vitamin c in apple juice you
get the same amount of vitamins
are you sure positive
when comparing apples to oranges oh
that's what we're doing today we're
comparing apples to orange yeah i know
oj is the clear favorite boom eight
ounces of one hundred percent natural
energy
has more than twice the amount of
vitamin c recommended by the usda for
children age 113.
pull me up pull me up vitamin c and
apple juice could you
it's it's an absurd if anybody's getting
their vitamins from juice
you're an idiot everybody knows when you
have a cold drink
by the way c content was an apple juice
highest vitamin c content was an apple
juice
more than the orange juices over
17 samples analyzed the one with the
whole
answer answer me this when when you're
sick and they say you gotta get vitamin
c why do they not say drink apple juice
really they also tell you to take uh
advil and and tylenol and things that
eat your stomach lining and do god knows
what else to your body
yeah you you but you know what i mean i
mean this is like an apple a day i'll
tell you what i'll tell you what why
don't you make a garlic rub and put it
on your chest
to clear up your congestion that's
probably a good thing yeah i mean come
on dude what kind of what kind of
lives prairie [ __ ] are you talking about
right orange juice is is associated with
health benefits
at large and i in popular culture and i
don't think apple juice is it's a
misconception though
why i've heard it since i'm a little kid
because there is a false narrative about
orange juice that's not true they say
have a lot of liquids drink orange juice
when you have a cookie they never say
drink orange juice are you
bat crazy they never say drink they say
drink orange juice they say drink juice
drink with fluids
okay both of america's most popular
juices are delicious low-calorie
beverages and many nutrients and no fat
but if you're choosing go for oj it's
known as a vitamin c
powerhouse and boasts almost twice the
potassium of apple juice
apple juice has a healthful amount of
potassium and vitamin c
but lacks folic acid okay and can we
give the source please of where this
information
this comes from cookinglight.com so it
must be accurate
it's under the eating smart choices it
must be accurate i want to see
who did the study can you go back to the
previous page mike
so i can see who did the 17 sample study
of of uh apple juice there it is right
there
you you re what is that eureka alert
dot org i mean look the juices contain
more vitamin c than their labels
indicate there you go
this is a real stuff there you go this
is nothing it's
that look how legitimate this website
was
you just said there you go based on
nothing
like you just won a point there look how
legit this website looks you
don't you don't trust this website look
at the initials at the top aaas
i don't know it looks fine to me
american association for the advancement
of science
that's i that that yes that holds water
over cookinglight.com
yes so what does it say it's this is the
website that said they sampled
17 different things and apple juice far
and away had the highest vitamin c
count yeah but it doesn't have the folic
acid and potassium oranges
i'm telling you there's a reason why
doctors used to say drink a lot of
liquids drink orange juice if you're not
feeling well you should say eat an apple
a day and it keeps the doctor waiting
for that no no no don't step on that
don't step on what i just said
they said i got a signal they said eat
an apple a day it keeps the doctor away
remember that yeah that's a great
that's a way more famous doctor saying
then drink orange juice no it's not
yes when you have a cold they say drink
plenty of liquids make sure you drink
orange juice they say that all the time
it's just as much
just as much by the 1980s people started
to realize that the healthy alternative
was not so healthy this is when not from
concentrate oj
emerged the kind that many of us have in
our homes today
not me being a surprise when i was
younger
when i was little my grandma and my my
mama aunt they used to like get the
frozen
yeah they popped it open like a
pillsbury dough thing and they just
dumped it in water and slushed it
that was like orange drink that stuff
was you know what was great with that
though
was you could drink it before it was all
thawed and it was like having an orange
ice cream yeah you could get the chips
in your mouth uh not from uh contrary og
emerge
the kind that many of us know being a
supposedly a healthier option not from
concentrate oj soon became the most
popular choice
that's wild and that's from an article
may 2020.
that's wild because not from concentrate
oj is
not good no no not from concentration oh
sorry
correct i'm telling you it's the end of
a 10-hour day yeah i know i
look i told you you were batty on the
last one so you were saying from
concentrate oj before the 80s
yeah they were the tip was the standard
yes and come in the 80s
not from emerge and god bless us so
we're only drinking not from did you
know
for 40 years you told literally a story
from your own life
of exactly what that was describing and
you still didn't understand what it was
you were reading
i am you literally said when i was a kid
my mom would get the frozen guy
because not from contra it's almost like
non-fiction and fiction
like in my head not from concentrate is
the good stuff but when i was just
reading it really quickly
i was like awesome concentrate is the
good stuff right yes yes
your battery in my head from concentrate
is not from country it feels like it
annotates that it's not the good stuff
with the word not in it like non-fiction
feels like it's not real
but it is non-fic you know what i'm
saying
listen don't listen orange juice is
better than apple juice all right let's
go to the phones
let's go to the phones are we at are we
at has it been that long yeah we have to
we have to get
here's one thing we have to do we have
to get the pole
out more closer to the top of the app so
we have more time to vote
thousands yeah but still responses still
all right fair enough i'm not against it
okay uh here we go
somebody's gonna eat humble pie okay
holy [ __ ]
so okay let me just say a couple things
no i know what you're doing you won and
you're not you're going to try to make
it sound like i want so you can rub it
in my face
just hold on yeah okay all right just
hold on all right yeah go ahead please
hold on
okay first of all uh i realized that at
the other two pulls i put like hey we're
doing a podcast choose between this less
peop
clearly less people see it because it
took in this amount of time only 3 000
people voted
but in this amount of time when i just
put better juice i guess this is an
algorithm i'm just saying
you need to know the business of this
but why not we're being transparent uh
already 14 000 people voted on this one
really and last time we had
way more votes than this time so i guess
putting some business of a sentence
beforehand
instead of just going better this we do
not get as many as
you know so there'll be other ones who
are topping out at 3 000 votes this is
14
000 votes in 22. before you give the
results let me ask you one question
do you have enough of the couch are you
comfortable you could do whatever you
want look at me over here
come on stop it listen to me you're not
ready for this
you're not ready for this i'm not ready
i'm not ready for this
i think one thing folks that's happened
during this last year
is we've all felt that we want to be
more productive we've had a lot of
downtime and we've all felt that we
could be more productive
and sometimes in certain ways we are
more productive but
i still feel like we're all looking for
tools to
push that even further okay that's where
ship station comes into play
yeah you like this service because i
love it oh top notch
i love it yeah look here's the thing you
got an online business you know you got
an online store you're doing your thing
from home you're selling some products
out of your house
or does it come in fast now you got to
ship them out what are you gonna do yeah
god knows what it is you're selling i'm
not here to judge
as long as it's legal ship station makes
this part of it easy
with ship station it's simple to import
manage and ship your orders out fast
for a lot less money again no brainer
it's no wonder ship shipstation is the
number one shipping software for
e-commerce
e-commerce sellers with more five-star
reviews than anyone else
import orders from any sales channel
ship with any carrier
with using deeply discounted rates right
automate any shipping
tasks so what i like about this is with
my experience with this
product the hardest thing about an
online business the hardest thing about
doing something from home the startup
thing the true startup thing you know
uh when it really is just you doing your
thing which i have done throughout my
career
it's so daunting when you think about
how do i get
what i have here to those people over
there and shipstation has made that so
incredibly easy for me in on all fronts
i i just it's it
they are taking away the bureaucratic
system that is preventing you from
doing your thing no you're talking now
yeah you are sorry i'm saying they're
doing god's work here the thing that
is cool that i think is the coolest part
of it is it doesn't matter where you're
selling so if you're selling on amazon
you're selling on etsy or even your own
like website they funnel your orders
ship station funnels the orders into one
interface
and then you can manage it from anywhere
and you can even manage it from your
cell phone so
it really does streamline the process uh
ship more and less time just use our
offer code taste buds
to get a free 60-day trial that's two
months free of no hassle stress free
stress free shipping just go to
shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in taste buds that's
us
that's shipstation.com enter the offer
uh code taste buds
makeshift happen make ship happen oh and
now i get that that's cute all right
cute i like it you wanna hear a joke
always what did i say
when i called fresh on the telephone
today
hello friends hello fresh
[Laughter]
hello fresh one of our sponsors we love
these guys
sending you fresh pre-measured
ingredients mouth-watering seasonal
recipes delivered right to your door
skip those trips to the grocery store
who doesn't want to do that
with or without a pandemic or a lockdown
or whatever
who wants to go to the grocery store
you're squeezing sideways down those
aisles think about it
gross store
yeah yeah it's right there in the name
yeah you're always sliding against some
guy in the seasoning aisle you know it's
too close to eating out with that guy
it's too close for comfort uh listen
here's the thing hello stress is going
to cut out the
stressful meal planning uh the the trips
to the grocery stores we said
but the best part is is you're gonna
cook and get your dinner
on the table in about like 30 minutes
which
if you work like i do like sal does
like mike does over here i mean it's
like you know you don't always have the
energy man
and sometimes a drive-through is not a
good idea yeah
yeah and the options are there there's a
wide variety
easy delicious recipes there's options
for all three meals a day
every snack in between special treats
it's got it all uh and get a better
value hellofresh is 28
cheaper than shopping at the grocery
store
and 72 cheaper than a restaurant meal
without sacrificing the quality so
they're giving you cheaper stuff
quality stuff it's quality stuff for
cheap saving you the trip
and letting you get a healthy meal in
fast food time
you know for me it's amazing i'm
notoriously uh i do not cook
and so when we got to try this because
they came on as a sponsor
they delivered it to the house and i
actually cooked a meal
and it is a cathartic fun experience and
it gave me a little confidence because
it's easy to follow
right and now all of a sudden i feel
like oh maybe i could open my own
restaurant and be like a chef
i like what they do because i feel like
it's a cooking show in a box i feel like
when you watch a cooking show it's tough
because
it's you know they've got everything
prepared everything's ready to go blah
blah blah
i feel like hellofresh is saying no this
is like when you watch the show and you
said well i wish i just had all that
ready
they got it ready for you yeah so go to
hellofresh.comtastebuds12
that's hellofresh.com tastebuds one two
and use the code tastebuds12
for 12 free meals including shipping
they're literally giving the stuff away
that's 12 free meals including free
shipping at hellofresh.com
taste buds 12 when you use the promo
code
taste buds 12. what's better than free
food
you're not ready for this you're not
ready for this
come on this is going to be a
mind-blowing thing
it's going to be mine blowing a thousand
people 14 000 people voted are you ready
i'm not even going to say it i'm showing
you ready for this
are you kidding me are you kidding
me this is a this is a taste buds first
14 000 votes we are dead at
50 50. uh apple just took the slight
lead
because pimp voted apple what is that
apple you change it by 0.3 no but on on
the app it doesn't give you percentage
points
but on the on the website that we're
looking at it breaks it down to
actual percentage on the app if you can
see this it literally is
50 50 after 14
000 votes look at this
14 500 votes 50 50.
apple is is leading by 0.1 this is
wild this is nice i never thought that
that it would be 50 this is nuts
this is the biggest battle we've ever
seen these this is nice 14
500 votes 50 50. and if you get if you
want to be accurate because people are
voting
i mean in the time we sewed this another
thousand people voted
another thousand yeah in the last 30
seconds
refresh mike and now we have
straight up 14-4
oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh oh dead out of here get out of here
come on
15 000 votes fifty point one
percent apple versus forty nine
point nine percent whoa this is
unbelievable oh the thrill of victory
the agony and defeat oh my god it feels
good
i can't believe that that feels so that
feels better than a pummeling
it feels better than a pummeling this is
unbelievable and it's holding
it's holding strong it's holding that
extra point one percent you're afraid
right now because he's gonna refresh in
two seconds
he's refreshed it twice
it's 50 50 look at this i'm hanging on
50.1
honestly we got to go to this yeah of
course we got to go to this
oh my god that feels so this is wild
yeah 50 50. wow
i did list apple juice first oh come on
you won
the last two that's got nothing to do
with it
of course i'm taking a w i won yeah i
won that's the way the orange peels baby
wait a second but my phone is 50 50. i
don't care what your phone is
that is more accurate that's the desktop
website of twitter
i won by 0.1 and it's holden
it's holden he's refreshed three it's
four times it's holding caulfield
i don't believe this that's the win baby
50 on the phone though that's the winner
50 50 on the phone you're winning
you're gonna win 50.1 yeah it feels
better than a pummeling it really does
it feels this feels so good right now
i can't this feels so good i wish you
could feel it
i feel bad for you you can't feel how
good this feels right now
and you you were asking for this all day
oh you were running your mouth on the
other ones we recorded today
you were so arrogant on the other ones
oh
boy all right i can't i mean i i
actually i'm still reeling from this
like i don't know if i can i don't know
mike scroll down please and i'll read
some tweets because we got to wrap this
up
oh my god viper bigly it says thirsty
are in the market for some fun
they're two very different beverages uh
whoever is voting apple you can come
fight me right now
uh that's a contender for best tweet uh
apple
only good orange just has either
champagne or vodka in it i agree
used to think orange juice was the best
that i grew up
apple juice is the best juiced ever sal
shouldn't even be a debate okay
whoa whoa whoa best of the two oh forgot
sorry i'm not reading that one because
we hate when people do that
keep going impress oh man this is this
is a
this is i mean we are we i mean we're
the only ones
within only a wedding within only a
handful of episodes we have had
just ins this is these are insane
battles this was a good this was this
was
this is unheard of i i i would venture
to say
that we may never ever i i this is like
hitting
like a light and getting hit by
lightning but this the
the lowest sliver of recordable
percentage
[Laughter]
the lowest sliver the closest you can
actually come
you can you can't achieve a closer score
than this
it wouldn't even it wouldn't even
compute it it doesn't go down on the
decimal point
that's right the closest you could ever
have is winning by point one
okay that will never happen again that
will never happen again now
it does merit uh and we should make a
note of this
choose orange but only with champagne
baby
that's a good one that's funny oh my god
uh
our oh look at that one wait wait go
back orange gives you
orange gives you heartburn and at least
you can tolerate some apple juice after
brushing your teeth
great point watch this will be a dead
heat until the very end then pomegranate
will juice it will run in with the chair
it's 50 50 i'm sweating although i
picked orange juice they're both great
look at this monster that what this
monster wrote go back no no slide up a
little bit
look at this monster i'm calling him out
and aaron w
cranberry grapefruit tomato anything but
those two oh take a hot [ __ ] buddy
tomato that's insane tomato isn't a
juice it's
uh look at this ready you made his one
here's a great tweet you're missing an
option beetle
uh all right i think i think the winner
uh
of response is oh my god oh god
i'm gonna give the win i said the winner
was actually the first one that we used
to think orange juice was the best then
i grew up
it was either that one or there was one
right before that that we really liked
christina hutchinson says this is way
too neck and neck
apple juice for life oh i
i was my favorite was who whoever is
voting apple you can come fight me right
now
that was my favorite do you like the
other one better
we can give it to orange juice than i
grew up oh
man and then the champagne baby too
choose orange but only with champagne
baby actually maybe it's this because
that
that gif is so good
and that's really funny yeah all right
let's give it to this one all right
kalyn barrett is our winner at you can
follow kaelin
at k-a-y-l-y-n-n underscore
b-a-r-r-e-t-t
thank you caitlyn i can't take this loss
right now can you refresh again
yeah let's just go see it one more time
just i know
i know i know it's you you won but i
feel it's going to flip
oh my god 19 000 votes 50.1 to 49.9
this is one this is wild oh damn this is
a full-on barn burner right now
the results of this poll are insane
apple juice is for toddlers adults drink
orange juice yeah what's that person
talk about then i grew up
what i was saying i said when i was a
kid i liked orange juice and you get
older and it's it's just
it's you you stop believing the lie
oh my god oh my god all right
take this loss man all right joe
i still love you babe i love you too all
right
guys that's our show that was a hot one
now i don't even want to end this i want
to i want to i want to
i dare you i dare you to give me five
more minutes this is
no no we have a rule here at taste buds
which is now we will revisit this on a
later episode
this is this is this is going to be like
a like a like a like a like a rim like a
thrill
this is going to be a this is a
heavyweight rematch yeah this is a
heavyweight
rematch my friend yeah we will remat we
will revisit this in a later episode as
we said we would
if it was ever this close oh look at it
just sitting right there
it won't budge 50.1
oh god this is this is i'll never have a
victory this week in my life i don't
even care if i lose the rematch
this is so good right now it's so good
imagine we have a rematch and orange
wins which is very feasible
and then we have to have a rubber match
we have to have a it's a it's i mean
it's a trilogy match
this is i mean this is like i say if
this if if i win the next one on this
rematch
we we maybe have a live app oh we do a
live app
on it's like it's going to be like i
mean what's a famous trilogy frasier ali
is that is that a trilogy
what's one of the most famous trilogies
of all time indiana jones
no but i mean i know i'm kidding the uh
i don't know ocean's is 11 12 13.
uh there's gotta be yeah best trilogies
plus in boxing
sugar ray leonard versus duran
dejesus versus duran god duran's in two
of them
that's wild pacquiao versus morales
patterson versus johansen
did i read that wrong oh oh oh yeah i
didn't i don't know who ingmar
igmar johansen i don't even i've never
heard of that guy
uh all right folks that's the show
listen i mean
we will never be able to recreate this
what a show and i gotta admit
it started a little slow because we were
punchy yeah we were rambling and then
the debate wasn't too
heated so for it for it to end with this
twist
is just wow this is this was perfect and
uh pat walsh and i review uh horror
movies and such
on we'll see you in hell uh you can get
new episodes at patreon.com
wsyih podcast or old episodes wherever
you get your podcast
savilcanocomedy.com for any of my
touring
uh jokers and dinner party and misery
index are on tbs
and true tv uh and um
i mean this is this is tough this is a
tough loss
this is this is embarrassing this is a
photo finish
i do a podcast of course called hey babe
with christos stefano
check that out uh back catalog with q of
what say you maybe we'll do that again
and uh i don't know man i don't know
what i'm going to talk about i'm just
rambling now because
this is the toughest loss i've ever been
handed
all right it's no good see you next week
they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds